côté de ma gueule je vais vous attaquer
encore parce qu'il y a pas de faux chez
moi je vous êtes un pauvre mec
[Musique]
mais vous vous promettez à gauche de 11
ans qui seront de grands footballeurs
professionnels
vous êtes un pauvre mec je l'ai vous
aussi vous pouvez pas c'est pas possible
[Musique]
c'est parce qu'on déculpabilise ceux qui
se trouve une bonne raison qu'on a un
Front national si fort car si Le Pen est
un salon ce qui vote pour eux sont des
salons
la riposte de Jean-Marie Le Pen n'a pas
tarde le président du Front national
porte plainte demande aux électeurs de
trancher en votant pour lui et
contre-attaque j'ai l'habitude que ce
genre de personnage me traite de la même
manière mais après tout la base du
drapeau ne touche pas à chacun c'est la
blanche colombe
[Musique]
vous voyagez beaucoup vous avez une
vision internationale les Anglais quand
on les attaque qui se redresse avec une
certaine fierté nationale les Allemands
au plus fort de la récession et les
difficultés de la réunification il
s'adapte il serait organisent ils ont
confiance en eux pourquoi les Français
et comment on peut le combattre pourquoi
les Français hésitent entre temps en
temps la rébellion un coup et puis
l'abattement comment on peut les doper
j'ai envie de vous dire
bon je vais pas vous dire vous allez
trouver que c'est une conclusion
désagréable pour nous deux mais
vous êtes vraiment maso vous faites
semblant je vous dis à voyager un peu
plus et puis vous verrez que la France
ressemble presque le jour vous serez
allé en Chine ou en Russie aussi souvent
que moi
arrêtez de dire les journaux et vous
verrez qu'ils sont pas du tout ce que
vous êtes en train de dire
[Musique]
j'avais changé de des noms d'oiseaux
vous avez presque failli en venir aux
mains alors comme je m'en souviens j'ai
pris des attendez j'ai pris des quelques
précautions
grâce à la gentillesse de Décathlon ça
coûte rien à la maison France 2 alors on
sait jamais si ça se passe mal comme on
veut éviter des traumatismes ou des
coups il y aura les gants pour l'un ou
l'autre
aucun casque si ça se passe mal est-ce
que vous allez les utiliser à votre avis
ou pas nous nous avons pas utilisé nous
n'en avons pas besoin mais je les aurais
accepté si on en avait fait cadeau je
vois que la générosité d'Antenne 2 ne va
pas jusque là c'est uniquement un petit
effet de tribune entre les hommes
politiques et nous Bernard Tapie donc
attention également Pacifique c'est
sérieux la politique
[Musique]
c'est ma dernière question pourquoi
avez-vous le sentiment à ce point d'être
persécuté comme s'il y avait un des
médias des juges des politiques est-ce
que vous imaginez un seul instant que on
essaye de dire le droit regardez c'est
ce que j'ai dit juste avant de rentrer
quand un journaliste sait plus quoi dire
parce qu'il est conscient qu'il y a une
acharnement incroyable il dit mais alors
c'est un complot et nous comme des
imbéciles on n'a pas envie de dire oui
parce qu'on passe aux imbéciles oui
monsieur c'est un complot
[Musique]